he gonna smacks from max tech and today
we are reviewing something that's a
little bit different compared to most of
the tech on this channel but it is still
tech and tech that is quite impressive
now I've been a lover attack ever since
I was very young before I can even you
know recall and the same thing with my
kids now they're kind of leading in the
same footsteps or everything that I'm
kind of passing on and that's because
Tech has made a big impact on my life in
a number of ways both for entertainment
enjoyment and to improve your life all
of those kind of things and a lot of it
fits into this cylinder right here so
this is the molecule air purifier and
I've been using this for more than a few
weeks now and it really has made an
improvement in our quality of life now
I'm somebody that hasn't really suffered
with allergies for most of my life other
than the last two years where I was just
hit out of nowhere and then I'm starting
to get itchy eyes itchy throat my nose
is getting congested I'm having a hard
time sleeping when I wake up I feel
terrible and this spring was the worst
one out of all my wife has had allergies
in the past but it was never as bad as
this year and we were not sure what to
do I ended up buying little filters put
it on our central vents I bought the
most expensive best central a/c filter
that's HEPA we also have the electronic
a little contraption that zaps
everything and nothing was helping and
then somehow right in the right moment
molecule reached out and wondered if
they would be able to sponsor a video
send one of these out for us to test out
and I was like absolutely I've seen
these in the past and I've read good
things about him and that was the
perfect time so that's exactly what we
did I want to focus this video mainly on
my real-world experience and give you
guys just my honest review on this
device but I'll also talk about the
design and how it works and how it
really stands out from the competition
so first off this is a smart device even
though they don't market it hugely in
that way you do have an app that you
download and you initially set this
thing up it connects to your Wi-Fi that
way you can update itself if it needs to
and it's able to know it let you know
when you need new filters
all that stuff like that and through the
phone app you can actually adjust the
speeds and get notifications stuff like
that so if it's a little bit loud I can
put it into the auto mode or put into
the silent mode or if I want to give it
a boost I can crank it up and that's
been really convenient now on the
outside you guys see this is a
cylindrical shape and then we have this
really cool leather handle right here
for lifting it up and this thing is
really substantial so it's nice that we
have this we have plastic on the top
here with circular vents we have a
touchscreen display here and then the
air gets sucked in through the bottom
through a pre-filter that will filter
out a majority of the large debris x'
now on the inside there is something
called a pico filter it actually is has
a coating on there and then the light
activates that coating and it literally
destroys whatever it's filtering in so
you have a lot of VOCs viruses
everything that is sucking in it doesn't
just trap it there and then have like
mold growth over time it actually kills
it and that makes a big difference now
one thing that really stands out to me
is the look and the design now I'm not
somebody that needs something that looks
amazing but we recently bought our first
kind of nice house and we tried to make
everything look nicer and most of the
filters on the market they're big white
plastic boxes that really stand out they
don't look nice they don't really blend
in nicely they're really cheap feeling
and the kind of the nicer filters on the
market they're these big ugly like
rectangular metal boxes that look like
you know they're meant to be in a
hospital or something like that where
this thing and filters on destroys all
the things that's sucking in but it
looks super nice so it'll fit in nicely
as you guys see in my living room it
doesn't look like an eyesore and the
build quality is incredible like the
strap is super thick and durable so if
you like Apple products you like premium
products this is what the molecule kind
of gives you so just like the simple
design it's also very simple to use you
plug it in the initial setup is done on
your phone and then afterwards it just
connects your Wi-Fi and then you could
select the room size and then if you
want to go Auto speed which will
actually calibrate and then there's also
a boost mode which I personally like to
use when
move it from room to room my kids love
it I'll show you guess that in just a
second and then there's a silent mode
which is nice if you wanted to be
completely silent
honestly we rarely use the silent mode
because the auto mode is pretty much
silent if you have any kind of room
noise if you have central air if you
have kids running around you're not
gonna hear it there is also a night mode
which will turn off the lights in there
and that does make the filters less
effective and actually after eight hours
the the lights will turn back on
personally I don't have a problem with a
little bit of light coming out of there
but if that is an issue for you there is
that mode as well and my kids they
figured out the boost mode and as you
guys could see they have a ton of fun
with it they'll grab balloons and since
the ports at the top will actually kind
of make the air move up in a turbine you
can see they're just they're having a
blast so now I have to try to control
them from them putting it into a boost
mode all the time as you can see we use
the molecule both in our living room
and inside of our bedroom typically
maybe a half hour to an hour before bed
we'll move it over to our bedroom and
turn it on select kind of the medium
room size and our living room is much
larger but even then we'd select the
over 400 square feet option and it can
actually move about 600 square feet of
air every hour so I was no problem
filtering out all the room there so now
let's get to the most important part how
did the molecule impact life of me and
my family so personally I was really
hoping that there would be a big
difference and there actually was when
we put this in after a couple nights we
noticed that we're sleeping better she's
sleeping better I'm not getting the
itchy throat and honestly I thought
maybe this is springtime allergies kind
of fading away or something like that
but anyways I was happy so we kept using
it kept moving it back and forth at
night we put it into our bedroom and
then one night we came home really late
I was tired and we didn't put it into
our room we just left and living room
fell asleep and the next morning BAM it
hit me my throat is itchy my eyes are
itchy my wife was itching her eyes at
night and that's where I really realized
how much of a difference it was making
and then it wasn't some sort of a
placebo effect or anything like that and
overall my family has been very happy
with the molecule now there are a couple
of downsides first off Mike
just keep playing with it it's a lot of
fun for them but they keep putting it in
boost mode and touching it which I don't
like but that is kind of a trade-off
second it is on the more expensive side
especially if you compare it with a
cheap HEPA filters like I said that
wasn't enough to make a difference in
our house and all those stuff that we're
dealing with so they're not really in
the same category and then if you
actually look for filters and systems
that are higher-end that will filter out
VOCs viruses bacteria that's where the
price points are fairly similar but
where the molecule stands out is that
its app connected so you can actually
control it from your phone you don't
have to go and spin dials and stuff like
that it looks really nice so it blends
into your home and said I'm in a big
kind of ugly box and you can easily move
it around so that is think is where the
value comes in now the filters there 65
bucks so I mean you can actually auto
send it out to you or send you a
notification about it because it is a
smart device it can actually sense how
much of that filter has been used up so
thank you guys for watching if you have
any questions ask down in the comment
section below I'll do my best to answer
them we have links to the molecule if
you guys want to get some more
information or if you guys want to buy
one down to the description definitely
go and check those out there some really
cool videos really cool explanations if
you guys want to learn more this has
been max with max tech and I'll see you
in the next video